hey welcome back to New Rockstars it's
me Mt and Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania is set to show us the
wonders of the universe underneath the
MCU as Scott hope and Cassie make their
first visit to Janet van dyne's former
subatomic home as evidenced by the
amazing first trailer that had me
singing Elton John for the next two to
three days straight when are you gonna
come home
however in proper Ant-Man fashion it
isn't those big moments that you gotta
watch out for but those little ones
because while everyone was checking out
Jonathan Majors I think everybody missed
a non-jonathan but still major reference
to Avengers end game cleverly hidden
amongst all that quantumania Mania but
where is it you might ask stick around
and find out my nerd babies good news
you don't have to shrink yourself down
to see wonderful things because you can
just head on over to new
rockstarsbirch.com right now to see all
of our wonderful new merch items for you
including our latest Obsession shirts
inspired by house of the Dragon check
out all of our amazing shirts and all of
our amazing other nerd options over in
Rockstar's merch.com today all right
gang so as I said before in like the
trailer shows Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania is set to finally reveal to
us a secret of the quantum realm the MCU
has been teasing us since like the first
Ant-Man movie but one of the biggest
secrets that will be explored in this
movie is primarily Janet van dyne's time
in the quantum realm a time that I
believe we see a brief flashback shot of
in the trailer right here with a hooded
Jenna Van Dyne sitting in the Forefront
of a white shot that looks like flares
or something heading directly for these
massive holes in the background this
shot right here my nerd babies hold the
Avengers endgame Easter egg why well
okay let's think about it Jenna Van Dyne
was trapped inside of the quantum realm
for decades after seemingly sacrificing
her life to defuse a bomb on a covert
superhero Mission as the original wasp
decades ago ever since then she has had
a whole nother life in the quantum realm
and became acclimated to how things work
there using her genius level intellect
and curiosity to learn all about the
Flora and Fauna of that little tiny
universe so much so that she even
managed to develop a device to
communicate with the faceless and
mouthless subatomic entities that live
in the quantum realm's weird habitats
but speaking of those habitats Janet
knew a lot about those too and we see
the strongest in the post-credits scene
for Ant-Man and the WASP when Janet is
preparing Scott for his trip to the
quantum realm to gather up Quantum
healing particles for ghosts take note
of what she said is right here also make
sure you stay out of guitar to grade
Fields they're cute but they'll eat you
and don't get sucked into a Time Vortex
we won't be able to save you and Janet
is right because the tardigrade fields
are something that we see earlier on in
the movie when Hank almost gets eaten by
some tartar greats himself on his way to
rescue his subatomic science spouse just
real quick this video is brought to you
by the ridge the ridge wallet is like
sleek and Industrial it's designed to
fit in your front pocket unlike those
bulky back pocket wallets that we won't
talk about here because this is a ridge
wallet so it holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash the ridge wallet
comes in over 30 styles and colors
including carbon fiber and burped
titanium that's how I like my titanium
burnt there's even an 18 karat gold
plated wallet if you're balling like
that which I think Aisha and the other
shiny Sovereign folks from Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 2 would appreciate
because they all about that gold life
they they be golden 24 7. and every
Ridge wallet comes with a lifetime
guarantee and they'll let you test drive
it for 45 days and send it back for a
full refund if you don't love it but
that's highly improbable because they
make the best wallet and it's got 30 000
five-star reviews and they also have
great backpacks and travel bags with
RFID blocking pockets and optional
device charging batteries and they have
a cool event going on now where every
dollar spent on the website before
September 18th enters you to win a 2020
Jeep Gladiator or fifty thousand dollars
if you prefer cash and are really
excited to paint yourself gold to match
your new Ridge wallet because that's
what you do but you know just don't
affect yourself with chemicals right
so get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com new rockstars that's Ridge
r-i-d-g-e.com Slash new rockstars and
use the code new rockstars and you can
find the link in the video description
below of course and Janet mentioning
time vortexes was of course the MCU
teasing the timeline hopping Heist of
Avengers end game right after this movie
where the Avengers use the quantum realm
to access different timelines to get the
Infinity Stones however let us slow down
and watch what happens to the Avengers
as they make this trip because as you
can see before the Avengers arrive at
their own respective timelines for the
time eyes each team shrinks down and
gets converted into a ball of light
before being sucked into one of these
weird blue pores that bring each team to
a different time Vortex I believe this
is what we are seeing Janet Van Dyne
witness in the quantum realm in this
shot of the quantumania trailer this is
Janet camping out in front of a bundle
of time vortexes as mysterious objects
break off into glowing energies to make
their way into said vortexes like
they're maybe chatting into their own
little massive hole in the background
because if you think about it for her to
warn Scott about them she naturally
would have to be very familiar with them
herself and actively have seen objects
go into these vortexes never to return
so us getting a glimpse of what these
time vortexes looked like from Janet van
dyne's perspective during her adventures
in the quantum realm makes sense for
this movie however if this is true the
question Still Remains just who or want
to be heading towards a Time vortex in
this trailer shop what do you guys think
because I think it'd be really fun if it
was secretly hang variants about to
invade the sacred timeline branches you
know after they were freed at the end of
the Loki finale because if you look
really closely these glowing flares in
the trailer seem to emerge from like a
portal of sorts almost similar to the
effect that happens when a spaceship
uses a jump portal in the Guardians
movies it's like a little energy crack
in space time or something so I'm
thinking that this could be some Kings
entering the MCU for the first time and
like about to enter some time vortexes
to enter their various timelines all I
know is that I am interested to hear
your thoughts in the comment section
below what do you guys think but thank
you guys so much for watching this video
you can follow me at Mass retainment if
you guys want to see me tweet some weird
[ __ ] more importantly you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on the social
media and also hope to give this video a
thumbs up if you liked it it always
helps out the channel also going to new
rockstars merch.com helps the channel
immensely and gives you some amazing
merch to wear to all of your family
gatherings head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com today thank you guys
so much for watching this video I love
you guys so much and I'll see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]